all right. I am back from vacation. The whole
team is back. I'll have some pretty good vacations.
He's actually from very sunny and Humid Aruba,
uh, on today's bonus show. But one of the
things that I did during the break, or I guess
sort of didn't do, I completely tuned out
political news and really news of all kind
during the vacation. And then when I got back,
I started the process of catching up on what
I'd missed to be ready for today's show. And
it gave me some really good perspective in
a sense, I missed a ton, including a ton of
erratic on hinged statements and actions from
Donald Trump. And yet here we are 10 days
since the last new show. And in a sense, nothing
has changed and I want to see if I can explain
it in a very particular way. Lots of things
happened while I was gone, but nothing changed
in that Trump is still a threat to our economy.
Trump is still a threat to the planet.
Our allies are still disgusted with Donald
Trump. And our relationships with other countries
continues to continue to be worse than they've
been in a very long time. And what we have
to understand is that the media outrage rounds
that take place with every stupid and crazy
thing that Donald Trump does don't change
the reality of the policy that the Donald
Trump administration is putting out there.
So while I was gone, Donald Trump said, migrants
at the u s border under U s custody won't
get the flu vaccine. This is horrible. This
leads to actual deaths. The administration
is exceeding their own limit for how long
people are supposed to be held. Uh, and and,
uh, ignoring their own limit that they've
placed. Trump said Jews who vote for Democrats
are disloyal to Israel, which is of course
premised on a totally antisemitic notion of
dual loyalty to Israel in the U s that American
Jews supposedly have according to people like
Donald Trump.
When Danish leadership told Donald Trump,
Greenland isn't for sale, Trump or radically
canceled his visit there. I mean, just a total
embarrassment globally on all fronts. Despite
having said he was going to push for gun control,
a, a gun background, uh, gun safety regulations
in the form of universal background checks.
Trump has bowed to the NRA and said, Nah,
not interested in doing those background checks
anymore. Trump called himself the chosen one
during another one of these erratic rants.
Any one of these would have been a scandal
at any point during the Obama presidency.
This was one week of Donald Trump while I
was on vacation, and I'm sure I'm missing
things by the way, but in end, nothing changed
during those 10 days. The immigration policy
of the Trump administration is a humanitarian
emergency. It was before my vacation and it
continues to be. Our trade policy was a self-destructive
joke before the break and after it.
It's worse now, and I'll talk about that later
on in the program. I don't mean that there's
no impact for each of the things that Donald
Trump does. Trump says, no flu vaccine, people
die of the flu. I mean this is very real in
that sense. But what I mean is that the big
picture has not changed. We have an erratic
ignorant megalomaniac who is in charge of
the United States. The Republican Party is
halfway complicit and halfway in different
and some sliver actually likes it. And we
need to be focused on making the big changes
that will put a stop to this, which starts
with removing the president. But it's got
to include taking control of back of the Supreme
Court and the lower courts, which increasingly
with every passing month Donald Trump controls
more and more of we've got to repair the relationships
with other countries. You know, starting to
be reasonable with people around the world
instead of being the petulant child that everyone
ignores because there's no reasoning with
them.
And I've said this before and I'll say it
again. This is a daily show that I do. Uh,
and what I tell you is what's going on. I'm
going to continue to make the effort to contextualize
it, explain why the day to day matters. Explain
what we can do something because we need to
be doing more than the outrage porn stuff.
No one really benefits from that. This isn't
me saying let's bury our heads in the sand
and ignore the news, but it's, let's be more
thoughtful and, uh, specific about how we
work with the news that we hear and actually
try to turn it into something activism, knowledge
that becomes usable, catalyzing voting. It's
got to go beyond the outrage porn and not
paying attention to the news for this week.
Confirm that. Number one, it's important to
pay attention to the news, but we've gotta
be doing it in a particular way where we understand
that each individual news story is not changing
or shaping the bigger picture.
And the bigger picture is the important context
that we need to understand. So that, that's
my sort of refocus as I come back from the
vacation. Uh, and a lot of that is going to
happen immediately on this show and in fact,
we've got to go to trade policy next.